This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the beginning, there was design. At least according to designer and author will live well. Design is the oldest human discipline, older than humanity itself. And will believe that in this oldest of old disciplines, everything ever designed. Spaceships, buildings, pyramids, weapons, clothing, artwork, everything. Can be traced back to a single designed object, the first designed object. This is as close to a genesis object as we have, I mean, this is where it all began. If design had its own Cosmo series, this would be episode one.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。起初，有了设计。至少根据设计师兼作家威尔·利德威尔的说法是这样的。设计是人类最古老的学科，比人类本身还要古老。威尔认为，在这门最古老的学科中，曾经设计过的所有东西——宇宙飞船、建筑物、金字塔、武器、服装、艺术品，一切的一切——都可以追溯到一个单一的设计对象，即第一个设计对象。这就像我们所能拥有的最接近起源的对象，我的意思是，这就是一切开始的地方。如果设计有自己的《宇宙》系列纪录片，这就是第一集。
I think this is the greatest, grandest, like most interesting story in the field of design. It has it all. Mystery, entry, controversy. We are on the edge of our seats, Will. Wait for it, I need like the drum roll here. The first design object was the Ashulian Handaxe.
我认为这是设计领域中最伟大、最宏大、最有趣的故事。它应有尽有：神秘、悬疑、争议。我们都屏息以待，威尔。等等，我需要一段鼓声。第一个设计对象就是阿舍利手斧。
The Ashulian Handaxe, ladies and gentlemen, actually it doesn't look like an axe at all. There's no handle, there's no metal. Honestly, it should be called the Ascholien pointy hand rock. A hand axe is made of rock and it's teardrop shaped. And if you join your hands together, is if to pray, fingers together and thumbs in, this is almost the exact shape in size. I'm an Ascholien hand axe.
女士们先生们，阿舍利手斧其实看起来一点也不像斧头。它没有柄，也没有金属。老实说，它应该被称为“阿舍利尖头手石”。手斧是用石头做的，呈泪滴状。如果你把双手合十，就像祈祷一样，手指并拢，大拇指内扣，这几乎就是阿舍利手斧的形状和大小。
The term Ascholien refers to where the first specimens were found, which was a dig site in St. Ashul, France, but they've been found in a lot of other places. We find that Ashulian tools are found almost exclusively in Africa, in Europe, and South Asia. This is Terence Deacon. I'm Terence Deacon, a professor of biological anthropology at the University of California Berkeley. And Berkeley has a whole bunch of samples of these hand axes.
“阿舍利”一词指的是发现第一批标本的地方，即法国圣阿舍利的一个挖掘点，但它们在许多其他地方也被发现。我们发现阿舍利工具几乎只在非洲、欧洲和南亚被发现。这是特伦斯·迪肯。我是加州大学伯克利分校的生物人类学教授特伦斯·迪肯。伯克利收藏了大量这些手斧的样本。
There's another hand axe. You can see that it's not quite so symmetric and nice, although it's sharp at this edge. Some are sharp all along the entire perimeter, some aren't. Some are perfectly symmetrical and some are not. But those hand axes in the UC Berkeley Basement aren't actual primordial hand axes. These are replicas made by graduate students. Yes, graduate students. In fact, there have been courses here in which one of the challenges is to make tools.
这是另一把手斧。你可以看到它并不那么对称和美观，尽管它的边缘很锋利。有些手斧整个周边都很锋利，有些则不然。有些非常对称，有些则不是。但加州大学伯克利分校地下室里的那些手斧并不是真正的原始手斧。这些是研究生制作的复制品。是的，研究生。事实上，这里曾开设过课程，其中一项挑战就是制作工具。
And the point of this challenge for the graduate students is to see how involved this process is in making one of these pointy rocks, the way the early humans would have. If you break off big pieces with large rocks and large strikes, and then you break off these little edges, you shape the edge with smaller pieces. I just love the image of a bunch of grad students sitting around smashing rocks together, and sometimes they have to do it for a while. Someone really practiced at it can make a hand-axe in something like 15 minutes to a half hour. But to make a really fine tool, really carefully shaped tool, you're probably
研究生们进行这项挑战的目的是为了看看制作这些尖头石头的过程有多复杂，就像早期人类所做的那样。如果你用大石头和重击敲下大块碎片，然后敲掉这些小边缘，你就可以用较小的碎片来塑造边缘。我真的很喜欢一群研究生坐在一起敲打石头的画面，有时他们必须这样做很长一段时间。一个真正熟练的人可以在15分钟到半小时内制作出一把手斧。但要制作一个非常精细、精心塑造的工具，你可能
talking about an hour to two hours. Ascholian hand-axes required time, effort and skill to make. They were a product of a design process, the first design process. But the Ashulian Handax was not the first tool. The first tool was basically a rock that is chipped with just a handful of major strikes to produce a few sharp edges, not very sophisticated tools. And they're probably just called these old wand tools. Our homohevelers ancestors used them to bash open bones and scrape meat off of them
需要一到两个小时。阿舍利手斧的制作需要时间、精力和技巧。它们是设计过程的产物，是第一个设计过程。但阿舍利手斧并不是第一个工具。第一个工具基本上是一块石头，只需几次重击就能产生几个锋利的边缘，这些工具并不太复杂。它们可能被称为“奥杜威工具”。我们的直立人祖先在200万年前用它们来砸开骨头并刮下上面的肉，
around 2 million years ago, though this kind of technique isn't unique to humans. This can be done even by South American monkeys, the Caffage and monkeys. They get these large pine nuts and they have hammer stones that they can then lift up and bash these things until they open them. They know what they want to achieve, but they actually simply go out and select something that will accomplish that. Rather than actually design something.
尽管这种技术并非人类独有。即使是南美猴子，即卷尾猴，也能做到这一点。它们拿到这些大松子，然后用锤石举起来砸这些东西，直到它们打开。它们知道自己想要达到什么目标，但它们实际上只是出去选择能完成任务的东西，而不是真正去设计什么。
Chimpanzes in, for example, stripping the leaves and the side branches off a little branch, they can stick it down, a termite nest and get the termites to bite it, as they can eat the termites that way. So this requires cunning, yes, but craft, not really. So early humans understood the importance of all the wand tools, those sharp rocks, and they realized that they could fashion more precise tools by sharpening rocks purposefully. So it's not just adventitious production, now it's planned production. So the hand axe is the first designed object, at least that we can find.
例如，黑猩猩剥掉小树枝上的叶子和侧枝，然后把它们插进白蚁巢穴，让白蚁咬住树枝，这样它们就可以吃掉白蚁。这确实需要狡黠，但算不上工艺。所以早期人类理解了奥杜威工具（那些锋利的石头）的重要性，他们意识到可以通过有目的地磨尖石头来制作更精确的工具。所以这不再是偶然的产物，而是有计划的生产。因此，手斧是第一个设计对象，至少是我们能找到的第一个。
If there were any, say, wooden tools that our human-like ancestors made, those of long sense disintegrated. But even if there are other examples, hand-axes are really significant. With the Ascholian hand-axe, with the Ascholian technology showing up, we suddenly now find people making people, I say they're ancestors, making tools with an end in mind. They're making them in advance. They almost certainly have to carry them with them.
如果我们的类人祖先制作过任何木制工具，那些早已腐烂消失了。但即使还有其他例子，手斧也确实意义重大。随着阿舍利手斧和阿舍利技术的出现，我们突然发现人们——我是说他们的祖先——开始带着目的制作工具。他们提前制作它们。他们几乎肯定必须随身携带它们。
They don't just make them on the spot. They take time to make them, they take thought to make them, and you're shaping them towards a particular shape for some particular use, which we today don't know. We don't know. We don't know how they were used. That's the crazy mystery here. So this is where we get into the intrigue.
他们不是随手制作的。他们花时间去制作，花心思去制作，并且为了某种特定的用途将其塑造成特定的形状，而这种用途我们今天不得而知。我们不知道。我们不知道它们是如何使用的。这就是这里疯狂的谜团。所以这就是我们进入悬疑的部分。
That's Will Lidwell again. Their ideas, right? So smart people are working on the problem and there are like three theories. There are more than three. If you want me to talk about more theories, I can talk about more theories, but I'll stop at three unless you tell me otherwise.
又是威尔·利德威尔。这是他们的想法，对吧？所以聪明人正在研究这个问题，大约有三种理论。不止三种。如果你想让我谈谈更多理论，我可以谈谈，但除非你另有要求，否则我就讲到三种为止。
Will Lidwell has three favorite theories as to why the handaxe appeared. So all right, theory number one, right, of how is used is the multi-tool theory. So theory number one is that the Ashilin Handaxe was the original Swiss army knife, primarily used for butchering meat, but it's also good for
威尔·利德威尔有三个关于手斧为何出现的最喜欢的理论。好吧，理论一，关于它是如何使用的，是“多功能工具理论”。所以理论一认为阿舍利手斧是最初的瑞士军刀，主要用于屠宰肉类，但也适合
breaking open nuts and digging up grubs or whatever else you might need. And so the strength of this theory is that it fits with wear patterns that you see on a lot of the hand-axes that are found. Here's the problem with theory number one. In some cases, the full perimeter of the axe is sharp. And remember, this is a hand-axe that you're holding in the palm of your hand. So if you wanted to use it, there would be this sharp blade digging into your palm. Another problem with theory one is that some of the axes are symmetrical, which is a lot of extra effort
砸开坚果、挖掘幼虫或任何你可能需要的用途。这个理论的优势在于它符合在许多发现的手斧上看到的磨损痕迹。理论一的问题在于：在某些情况下，斧头的整个周边都是锋利的。记住，这是你握在手掌里的手斧。所以如果你想使用它，锋利的刀刃会扎进你的手掌。理论一的另一个问题是，有些斧头是对称的，这需要额外的努力，
that isn't really necessary if you're just using it to break up nuts or cut meat. And so to address some of those problems, we get into theory number two. And this is my personal favorite. The sexy hand ax theory. The quote unquote sexy hand ax theory proposes that these tools didn't have a use per se. They were created mostly as a way of showing off.
如果你只是用它来砸坚果或切肉，这其实没必要。为了解决这些问题，我们进入了理论二。这是我个人最喜欢的。“性感手斧理论”。所谓的“性感手斧理论”提出，这些工具本身并没有用途。它们主要是作为一种炫耀方式而创造的。
Like the feathers of a peacock. The goal wasn't to create a functional tool for butchering, but a symbolic tool for made attraction. And making these things is really, really hard. Why spend so much time doing it, unless you're showing off, right? You're showing the opposite sex what you can do. But there are a lot of experts who are doubtful of this one, including anthropologist Terrence Deacon.
就像孔雀的羽毛一样。目标不是创造一种用于屠宰的功能性工具，而是一种用于吸引配偶的象征性工具。制作这些东西真的非常非常难。为什么要花这么多时间去做呢，除非你在炫耀，对吧？你在向异性展示你能做什么。但有很多专家对此表示怀疑，包括人类学家特伦斯·迪肯。
Not all of them are beautiful teardrop shapes. They were all that nice and neat and symmetrical. There is one interesting exception, and I mean one. One beautiful 350,000 year old exception. A hand axe was located at the bottom of a kind of well in southern Spain. It looks as though bodies were tossed down here and one of things that found in this well, so to speak, it's just a cave well, is a handaxe that was made of a kind of rose quartz looking stuff really pretty and it
并非所有的手斧都是美丽的泪滴形状。它们并不都那么漂亮、整洁和对称。有一个有趣的例外，我指的是只有一个。一个美丽的、35万年前的例外。一把手斧被发现在西班牙南部一口井的底部。看起来好像尸体被扔到了这里，而在井里发现的东西之一——姑且称之为洞穴井——是一把由一种看起来像玫瑰石英的材料制成的非常漂亮的手斧，它
doesn't look like it was ever used. Not a sexy handaxe, but this may be the first indications that they're beginning to sort of grieve over the death of someone or that there is some kind of ritual issue here in which a beautiful handaxe is something I'm playing a role. Okay, okay. The world's third favorite theory is still a really fun one. Number three is pretty fun. Number three in a close follow-on to my favorite, to sexy hand axes, the killer Frisbee theory. And so, in the killer Frisbee theory, right hand axes were made to be projectiles, so thrown in the fashion of the discus and the Olympics.
看起来好像从未使用过。这不是一把性感手斧，但这可能是他们开始为某人的死亡感到悲伤，或者存在某种仪式问题的最初迹象，其中美丽的手斧扮演了某种角色。好吧，好吧。世界上第三个最受欢迎的理论仍然是一个非常有趣的理论。第三个非常有趣。第三个紧随我最喜欢的“性感手斧”之后，是“杀手飞盘理论”。在“杀手飞盘理论”中，手斧被制成抛射物，像奥运会上的铁饼一样投掷。
A lot of hand axes are found near river banks, and so the hypothesis goes that hunters would wait for herds of animals to come, and then they would bombard them with hand axes. This might not be enough to make a kill, but this don'ts would name a few and give the hunters an opportunity to charge. This hypothesis explains why it looks the way it does, right? Why the hand axes sharp all the way around, why it's so symmetrical, why it's so aerodynamic?
许多手斧是在河岸附近发现的，因此假设是猎人会等待兽群到来，然后用手斧轰炸它们。这可能不足以造成杀伤，但这些投掷物会使一些动物残废，给猎人冲锋的机会。这个假设解释了它为什么看起来是这样，对吧？为什么手斧四周锋利，为什么它如此对称，为什么它如此符合空气动力学？
Well, again, not all of them are sharp all the way around and perfectly symmetrical. Was it used like a frisbee or was it used like a weapon? I really have my doubts about that. I like the Swiss Army knife view, in part because it looks like it's a one tool fits all. It was clearly something that we see again and again and again and again all over the world. That means it was very effective and if you don't find a lot of diversity of tools, it was almost certainly used for more than one thing. But whatever the Handaxe was used for, it must have done a really good job because this
好吧，同样，并非所有的手斧四周都锋利且完全对称。它是像飞盘一样使用，还是像武器一样使用？我对此确实有疑问。我喜欢“瑞士军刀”的观点，部分原因是它看起来像是一种万能工具。它显然是我们一次又一次、在世界各地反复看到的东西。这意味着它非常有效，如果你没有发现工具的多样性，它几乎肯定被用于不止一种用途。但无论手斧被用于什么，它一定做得非常好，因为这个
basic design was used for a mind-blowingly long time. Hominid adults were literally teaching hominid children how to make hand-axes for more than a million years, passing the knowledge down from generation to generation. And so you compare that to any modern product life cycle, right? It's just crazy long. So long that our human minds can barely wrap our heads around it. We have no conception of what that time frame is. Our understanding of history is only what, maybe, 5,000, 10,000 years.
基本设计被使用了极其漫长的时间。古人类成年人实际上在超过一百万年的时间里教古人类儿童如何制作手斧，将知识代代相传。所以你把它与任何现代产品的生命周期相比，对吧？这简直长得离谱。长到我们人类的大脑几乎无法理解。我们对那个时间框架没有任何概念。我们对历史的理解只有，也许5000年、10000年。
That's our biggest understanding of history. We're talking about something that stayed the same, a culture that was constant for a million years. That's pretty remarkable. And no matter what the Ascholian handaxe was actually used for, just the mere existence of a designed object that is so old has huge implications. I often have students or colleagues think that designs a new field, like a 20th century
这就是我们对历史最大的理解。我们谈论的是某种保持不变的东西，一种持续了一百万年的文化。这非常了不起。无论阿舍利手斧实际上被用于什么，仅仅是一个如此古老的设计对象的存在就具有巨大的意义。我经常有学生或同事认为设计是一个新领域，就像20世纪的
invention, when in fact it's the most ancient of all academic disciplines. Before there was mathematics or engineering or science, or art or music or poetry, before there was philosophy, literature, religion, or even language, there was design. 99% invisible is produced by the Krakow-Jack team of Avery Trouffleman, Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, and me, Roman Mars. Whether you're building websites, you're doing industrial designer architecture to have that sense industrial designer architecture to have that sense of history, to have those roots to me as everything. Special thanks to Will Lidwell for bringing the whole Handak story to us.
发明，而事实上它是所有学术学科中最古老的。在数学、工程学、科学、艺术、音乐或诗歌出现之前，在哲学、文学、宗教甚至语言出现之前，就已经有了设计。《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯组成的克拉科夫-杰克团队制作。无论你是在构建网站、从事工业设计还是建筑，拥有那种历史感，拥有那些根源，对我来说就是一切。特别感谢威尔·利德威尔为我们带来了整个手斧的故事。
Will's book, Universal Principles of Design, is one of my two go-to recommendations for books about design. It's fun, insightful, quick hit, and cyclopedia of all kinds of design principles I consulted all the time, I highly recommend it. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced at the offices of Ark sign, an architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can keep up with all the comings and goings at 99PI on Twitter, Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify if you say hi. We usually say hi back.
威尔的书《通用设计原则》是我关于设计书籍的两个首选推荐之一。它有趣、深刻、快速，是一本涵盖各种设计原则的百科全书，我一直查阅它，强烈推荐。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Ark Sign建筑事务所的办公室制作。你可以在Twitter、Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上关注99PI的所有动态，如果你打个招呼，我们通常会回应。
And if you're chipping away your own hand acts, I recommend listening to an old 99% invisible. It's the perfect length for hand acts may keep. At 99PI.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你正在雕琢自己的手斧，我建议听听旧版的《99%隐形》。它的长度非常适合手斧制作。在99PI.org。来自PRX的RadioTopia。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。